[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight the White House has
released their offer for an immigration
deal their proposal gives so-called
dreamers essentially everything they
said they wanted legalization and a path
to citizenship so millions of people who
broke our laws to get here would receive
amnesty very few of the president's
supporters voted for that when they put
him in office last year and some of them
are upset about it and the left what's
their reaction like well having gotten
pretty much exactly what they demanded
they're enraged not only is Trump's
amnesty offer not enough they say it is
evidence of a racist plot according to
the ACLU quote the only community that
benefits from the supposed generosity
are white supremacists United We Dream
that's one of the largest Pro amnesty
groups call the proposal quote a white
supremacist ransom note the columnist
Shaun King said the plan proved that
quote the current operating philosophy
of Trump and the White House is white
supremacy immigration activist Eddie
Vail called the proposal a legislative
burning cross and the senior Democrat in
the House of Representatives said this
last night the president put forth a
plan that plan is a campaign to make
America white again they are changing
the character of our country by what
they are putting forth they bring a tear
to the eye of the Statue of Liberty and
they were in fear to the hearts of
people are here playing by the rules we
can go on and on and on it's everywhere
today you see the point they're telling
you this plan is something the Klan
could have produced it probably did okay
but is it we took those charges
seriously because we felt we should and
we started to take a close look at what
the White House is actually proposed we
found that the plan may be many things
not all of them good by the way
but it definitely isn't a form of white
nationalism not unless that term now has
the opposite meaning let's go through it
the White House proposal would legalize
about two million people who currently
have no right to be here that's a lot of
people for perspective 13 US states have
populations smaller than that
Barack Obama never enacted an amnesty
that big how many of those beneficiaries
are white now keep in mind that would be
the central question in any plan crafted
by white supremacist obviously well
let's see almost none of them hmm two
million more non-white people in this
country that's more than the total
population of Delaware or Nebraska
doesn't sound much like a legislative
burning cross but there's more the
proposal would also continue the current
system of chain migration until the
backlog of applicants has been exhausted
that would take years and years what
countries will be the top beneficiaries
of this new arrangement under the Trump
plan well if you guessed Finland Norway
the Swedish national sauna team nope
guess again no European countries are on
that list not one instead the plan would
admit nearly a million more immigrants
from Mexico and hundreds of thousands
more from India also Vietnam Bangladesh
the Dominican Republic and China the
Philippines - the plan would even bring
in more than 50,000 additional
immigrants from Haiti the country that
President supposedly hates surprised you
shouldn't be no matter what the race
baiters on television are telling you no
majority white countries send large
numbers of immigrants to the United
States and haven't in 50 years that
would not change under this proposal a
white nationalist plot in the history of
dumb and dishonest Washington talking
points that may be the dumbest and most
dishonest of all and it's poisonous - it
makes people hate each other and it
further divides this country and we do
not need more of that the people who are
repeating it ought to be ashamed of
themselves so of course they're not they
have to know they're lying then again
maybe they don't know they're lying
maybe they've actually convinced
themselves their rhetoric is true it's
possible the Democratic Party really has
gone that insane their new position as
that is that it's immoral to restrict
any kind of immigration from any country
in any amount for any reason ever even
enforcing our own existing laws the ones
that they voted for and passed in
Congress is now tantamount to a hate
crime Nancy Pelosi has been making that
case for months now the public doesn't
agree with any of this so by definition
Democrats are extremists on the subject
they don't care
this is their new electoral strategy
these are their new voters whatever it
takes so SOR say is an immigrant and a
former dreamer and she joins us tonight
I believe from Los Angeles to us thanks
off coming on thanks for having me on
again Tucker so um there may be things
about this plane you don't like there
definitely things that I don't like
about it but it's hard to see how a plan
that gives legalization amnesty and a
path to citizenship for more than 2
million people here illegally
none of them white is white supremacy
how does that work well I think we have
to take a step back and look at this
from the beginning the reason why we're
in this chaos situation of young
people's lives being on the line is
because the president rescinded daca the
program that gave undocumented young
people the ability to work and go to
school and drive and pay taxes he ended
that program and that is why we're in
this situation I don't believe it is I
want to ask you a question about the
discussion today not about the roots of
daca which I'm happy to debate with you
in some other forum I want to ask what
the response today to this proposal
released last night which is that it's
white supremacy and I would like you to
tell me if you could give me a crisp
answer and not filibuster I'd appreciate
it
listen it was Donald Trump who ended the
daca program and he did so because he
wanted to hold hostage and use as
bargaining chips the lives of 800,000
undocumented people who have been here
their entire lives who are American in
every single way and now what we're
trying to do is to create a second-class
citizen okay that's what this that's
what this program does it says so are
you not going to answer me this is
giving people who are here illegally are
getting amnesty and a path to
citizenship which is what you've been
asking for and you're calling that white
supremacy none of those
white supremacist at what price I'm not
calling it white supremacy I don't think
those words have come out of my mouth
they've come out of the mouth I'm not
calling the ranking Democrat what I am
saying is that this this plan what it
does is it creates a second-class
citizen because it says that the
dreamers can become citizens themselves
but they cannot sponsor their parents
they cannot sponsor their siblings and
those rights are different than the
rights that you have and you just said
earlier that this plan the two million
people that none of them are white which
is untrue because there are undocumented
white people there are 50,000
undocumented Irish people living in New
York you're absolutely right they're not
covered by this so that that's my only
point you're actually right there are
definitely undocumented dreamers who are
white Tucker
I absolutely believe you it's just it's
an intact
I don't care actually about race I do
believe you my only point is that what
you're seeing today is not an expression
of white supremacy so I wish you and
your friends would stop making that
point because it's a lie and it's
divisive that's my only point and
because it's not true and it makes
people hate each other it is a plan that
makes it is a plan that would
potentially make 2 million people who
are mostly people of color have less
rights than white citizens so that is
racist okay so it's racist you you
sneaky you come in the country illegally
as you did you have a moral right to
come into the country illegally let's
get the facts straight I came to the US
on a plane on a tourist visa so I did
not come into this country I thought
that you overstay I'm sorry I totally
misunderstood your bio if I did over to
say my visa but you didn't know the
country you know you are here illegally
okay so I guess that's what I just said
but if you are very legally you cannot
break the law it was their parents who
brought them to this right so you're
saying that the parents who brought them
to this country now have a moral right
to become citizens also and I'm
wondering where that right comes from
listen if I am now a US citizen and if I
want my mother to be able to come visit
me and to be able to come be with me as
a United States citizen I should have
that right you haven't a different
country you would be able to sponsor you
sneak into the country you bring your
child that child gets citizenship and
now you have a right to citizenship
because you're the one who caused this
problem that parent in the first place
by bringing your child's name illegally
but I have to work exactly no but why
should I be for that going back to the
point I was making at the beginning of
the segment which we are in this
situation is because of precedent and at
daca and then he tasked Congress with
coming up with us you want it you want
to talk about it naturally we are you're
not answering like that dreamer lives
should pay you don't have a dollar
no no so you're saying if I sneak into
someone else's country and bring my
child and the people that country are
kind enough to give that child
citizenship then I somehow deserve it
too because why why that's a simple
question why don't you give me a simple
answer I'm gonna tell you why the reason
why is because if this people become
United States citizens as they would
under this plan they should have the
rights of as every other American
citizen has why should this person if
we're making them citizens we don't want
then they should have the same rights as
every other United States citizen let me
ask really really quick so the ACL u--'s
described this as the supposed
generosity of giving citizenship to
people who are here illegally do you
think it's generous of the United States
to give citizenship to people who came
here illegally do you think it's
generous I think that we are we are
trying to talk about two different
things
no we're trying to try to talk about I'm
asking you a simple question do you
think it's generous to give people who
are here illegally citizenship I don't
think that it's generous to bring
families and create second-class
occupant no I don't I don't know what we
would bring in people who great brain
for the privilege of being an American
citizen you're definitely in that
category too but by the way
okay we're out of time Thanks